[音楽]
だろうクンもうすぐクリスマスだねそうだね
プレスまずは音もんぞさあところで太鼓の音はうるさいネイリスますだからしょうが
ないよ
あーブレゼント欲しいなぁ for maya 物欲に植えてな俺なんてクリスマス
ツリーが見えたそれでいいよ
嘘つけお前本当は女が機体だろうお前もだろう
生原曲大ゲンカつれなお前らな栗ずあったから来てそんな
いいじゃないかうわぁはい
女抱きです
はいために紅莉栖バスなんですけどもこんなとこにも変化している子供達がいました
あなたいへぇ今日はそんな君たちのために今お前の頭からも借りるんだけどみんなねで
カイくんロっぷりを使おう
クリスマスツリー作ったります家とかでナイスえっ
あります僕もないですねどういう過程で作りませんでしたちょっとちっちゃいのとか
できたやつを感じました
ああ
た3 c 過程をがも家族で作ったりしなんか決まっており飾り付けただけだよ
クソめんどかったすけどやっぱりいないグッズ松井って大きければ大きいほど
テンションが上がるんですよだけであの矯正てこの広い場所に来てるんでそれで我々は
大人のつから使えば相当でかい石塚にペースますつり作れるんじゃないかと思ってあの
冗談抜きで見た目とかいいでただただ大きさは乱して非常採用にでかい空手服部今日
作って勇者でも俺ぷれじぇんどがいいよ俺は女だけ
文句言うなお前早速作っていきます
そう
会葬儀でご覧くださいましことに最良のダンボールを準備しましたそれでチョコの緑色
位だってクリスマスツリーの森の部分でこっちで木の部分作ってホセをつくったり相続
品をつくったりしてまー今なければ結構いいクリスマスツリ作れると思うんですと
みんなで力を合わせて作っていきたいと思います準備はいいかー
炭や eager
せっかくのクリスマスだ電話けれど喘鳴がう
ずっとベイガーじゃあコア嫁早速作っていきましょう
ちなみにクリスマスツリーの大きさの世界一なんですけどやっぱ待って世界中のきた
110m すっ眠りじゃあ何をってクリスマスティって言うか9人でも良ければ良い
ほど気がすんだよいいねイヤー勝手なイメージだけど断ってたんですよ
僕も放送されちゃうねだダメだどうすれを世界を広かった
無理日本一大きな調べようと30m くらいと言われてるらしいです勝ったなぁこれ管
30メートルを超えるとも我々が降ったクリスマスツリーが日本で一番大きくです
なんて言う音を立ててましたせっかくだからそれで国内一応断ったクリスマス堤で見
出すためにまずさん2名とこういう場所が頑張って作っていきましょう
ああああああ
じゃ
[音楽]
このおっちゃより難しいしてはクリスマスツリーって草その上に伸びるやつなんで
バランスとるのがとってもず痩せ気がします
履いて外ちょっと難航しております guys 役割としてはアップあたりが茶色い分
昨日ねっこ高さが欲しいてどんどん高くしなきゃいけないんで作ってもらって僕は
クリスマスツリーの主役といってもそこではない星の部分を今から作ろうと思います楽
してんじゃねーよ
そう
あったカッターうん言ったらみんな
はっぱカッターああ
[音楽]
いやっほう
バッハ
[音楽]
はいというわけでちょっと日が暮れてきました why です根ざして完成するので
紹介チョキパー2できてるねだからなんだかなりそうな気がするんですけどがんばり
ます
[拍手]
[音楽]
ame
犬だよ fal レってパパプレベ fj
れてれるウェイ
でえっ
ran
ペクで体れてるっっテレ
ん
me
dee
[音楽]
me
yeah
[音楽]
ああああああ
えっ
[音楽]
me
teame
ええええええ
ブルーあっ